new york governor andrew cuomo's massive
nursing home
scandal just got a whole lot worse and
far more deadly
we're finding out exactly why cuomo has
been refusing to release new data
on the total number of deaths for months
that's because
new york's attorney general dropped this
bomb
accusing the state of under counting
coveted nursing home deaths
by as much as 50 percent that means up
to 5
000 more people died than andrew cuomo
told us about
it turns out the governor was right when
he said this
incompetent government kills people
incompetent government kills people more
people
died than needed to die in covet
that's the truth
now you would think the guy who says
incompetent government
kills people would man up and take some
responsibility
but so far every chance he gets he
blames somebody else
if you look at how many people died in
nursing homes in new york compared to
other states
we actually have a lower percentage of
people
who died in nursing homes but we had
more people die than any other state
that's a fact
if you died in a nursing home it's
called the nursing home death if you die
in a hospital it's called the hospital
death
it doesn't say where were you before
and if i'm a nursing home operator i say
don't say that person
died in my nursing home because they
didn't
they died in the hospital and if the
hospital did a better job
they wouldn't have died so why do i get
blamed for the death when it didn't
happen in my nursing home
i put my head on the pillow at night
saying i saved lives
that's how i sleep at night and i know
we have
if that's not bad enough for you
remember when people were dying on his
watch the governor had time to write a
book on
leadership and boast about how he
crushed the pandemic
cuomo was also happy to bask in the
limelight
holding daily news conferences and
eating up
all the media praise it won him an emmy
i wish i could say that my daily coveted
presentations were
well choreographed scripted rehearsed or
reflected
any of the talents that you advance they
didn't
they offered only one thing authentic
truth
and stability
but cuomo's arrogance doesn't end there
remember when he was
thought it was a good idea to go on cnn
and goof off with his brother this
was the actual swab that was being used
to fit up that double barrel shotgun
that you have
mounted on the front of your pretty face
so greg the governor caught covering up
a body count that he created
what do we do you got the four c's
you got the crime you got the cover-up
you got a cuomo at cnn
so he's in perfect shape do you think
any do you think cnn's going to cover
this
how are they going to cover it with
chris cuomo staring at you the whole
time
glaring at you saying leave my brother
out of this do here's the key
thing that uh we just we just learned
here the repo
the report says that people who were in
nursing homes
who were transferred to hospitals and
died should be counted as nursing home
deaths not hospital deaths right and so
the state says
see we never lied we reported all the
deaths
but no one is saying you didn't report
all the deaths
they're saying that you allocated the
deaths incorrectly
which surprised benefited the governor
right because now it looks like not that
many people died in these rest homes but
the fact is they got that
how did they get the disease well they
were in the rest homes where they caught
it from the people that were put in the
rest homes
thanks to governor cuomo so when that's
why you would say they died
in a nursing home but he doesn't like
that because then he might not win the
nobel prize
he's up for the nobel prize
dana to me this looks like democrats
failing up
you know the worse they do the better
media attention they get
um you know he'll probably run for the
democrat nomination at some point and
he'll
he'll herald his stewardship of the
covet 19 crisis in new york
as a launching pad even even after
we know what he did here and that's
what's corrupt about this
uh just uh in the last few minutes the
new york department of
health commissioners basically said this
this is
not a big this report is not a big deal
and he points to
um i think footnote 71
number seven you got to get 71. um to
get down there to say like
we always said this was the case um if
that were true then i don't think
leticia james who is the new york
attorney general
would have written the report and the
headline the way that she did i mean
she's also a democrat
so i don't think this is really about
party so much as it is
about government government checks on
each other you know
andrew cuomo had said at the beginning
of all of this that he was just
following what the federal government
guidelines were going to be
and then he basically stopped answering
a lot of questions about that
you know in his um book the publisher on
his book there's this
blurb on the back of it that says real
leadership he shows
requires clear communication compassion
for others and a commitment to
truth-telling
no matter how frightening the facts
could be except for that
the communication was muddled people
feel deceived
and he seemed to have a refusal to share
the frightening facts
and also now you have the health
commissioner saying that this this isn't
a big deal at all
because you got to look at footnote 71.
hey kati here's why we're really not
gonna
you know allow him to spin this is
because he's so arrogant
prances around like a peacock struts
around and
dunks on everybody anytime you question
anything he does
you know if he was humble and said you
know what i made a mistake i
screwed up you know the fog of war and
took a little accountability you'd think
differently about it
yeah andrew cuomo hasn't taken
a single second to reflect on what it
must feel like
for the families before and the families
now
that have been lied to about the cause
of death for their family members and
let's not forget that this was a
deliberate decision that was made by
governor cuomo he had the javits center
which was built into a massive hospital
that he did not use he had a massive u.s
navy ship
that was just docked on the hudson was
not
used and instead he made the decision to
force elderly people back into nursing
nursing homes and when people at the
nursing home said this is a very bad
idea why are you forcing us to do this
he told them to shut up and take orders
now he's a politician
and rarely are there any kind of account
is there any
accountability for politicians but i
think in this case there absolutely has
to be i mean this is like a criminal
level
of bad decision-making and
and just horrific cover-up and then the
arrogance on top of it to act like
everybody who has questions about
why their mother and father like janice
dean for example
our mother-in-law and father-in-law
passed away as a result of
deliberate policy decisions that were
made and then not reflected on
there has to be some accountability for
decisions like this when people's lives
are at stake well
i don't know if it's you but i feel like
you've been doing a lot of sighing into
the microphone like al
gore um are we are we being unfair
to governor cuomo at all
well yes i do think that you don't like
governor cuomo i've gotten that message
loud and clear
but i think that i take the attorney
anyway i take the attorney general's
report and as we've heard she's a
democrat so
it's not a matter of somehow some kind
of cover-up and secondly
it's not a matter of total deaths being
misreported
it's a matter of how you sort them out
the people who
uh died in the nursing home as opposed
to people who got sick in the nursing
home and then died in a hospital
so with that said it's not any cover-up
we know the total number of deaths and
we understand the extent of it in new
york state which of course everyone
knows got hit
early but i just you know what makes me
sad jesse is i don't think we should be
rewriting the history here by
somehow pointing at governor cuomo the
fact is that america
a nation that's now lost no more than
400 000
people uh you know our handling of the
pandemic
was really troubled because of a lack of
national leadership from the trump
white house and i think we have to just
say you know there was a vacuum there
cuomo held his daily briefings they got
attention because there was nothing at
the time coming from
the president governors all over the
country republicans and democrats had to
figure out how to handle this situation
on their own
some did a better job than others but i
don't think that
you know i think you got to give those
governors credit and i think you have to
say
trump made it very political everything
from you know
it'll be gone soon
to donald trump we're not talking about
donald trump what i'm saying
is that that lack of hang on let me
finish folks
that national lack of national
leadership is the real problem here and
according to the polls
if trump had taken this hospital he
might have won a second term
he said a hospital ship that cuomo
didn't use and people died
deal with that that was after that was
afterwards and again cuomo made a
mistake and i'm saying he made a mistake
he tried to try to limit the number of
people in the hospital bed so they
wouldn't go over capacity
but it turned out to be a tragic mistake
for many families
did you want to jump in real quick well
since we're talking about rewriting
history i just want to
correctly state the history of andrew
cuomo's comments about the national
federal government response he was
praising president trump
in march and april and may he was saying
the federal government was working well
with them they were giving them
everything that they needed even
california governor
gavin newsom was also saying the ex the
same thing
and this idea that the trump
administration wasn't taking it
seriously i mean this show
was taking the white house coronavirus
task force briefings
almost every day for weeks on end of
them talking about how they're working
with the states
to deal with this issue and if you look
at a place like florida and you compare
it to new york there's no question about
the local response and how each governor
has handled this problem
yep and it wasn't donald trump that put
sick people in nursing homes and then
covered it up
i seem to remember trump sending
hundreds or thousands of ventilators
because cuomo demanded it and what
happened to those ventilators
anyway all right up